did did I kill Michael Washington
it's such a strong name
I'm sure somebody the name like that
would
be very fond of themselves somebody who
walks down the street
and looks at their reflection in the
shop windows someone who
works on their fitness
takes much pride in what they look like
in the mirror so if I would have killed
a man like that I could tell you how I
do it I'd probably time down to a table
and prop his head up so he's looking
down at his body and I'd break shards of
glass from a mirror and I slide them
into his torso so he can see himself
if I killed him that's probably how I
have done it but
I don't think you should be asking did I
kill Michael Washington I think the the
real question is did he deserve to die